cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film une vie ailleurs réalisé par
olivier peyon avec isabelle carré et
ramzy bedia c'est en uruguay que si lui
retrouve enfin la trace de son fils
enlevé il ya quatre ans par son ex mari
avec l'aide précieuse de mehdi el par le
récupérer mais arrivé là bas rien ne se
passe comme prévu
l'enfant élevé par sa grand mère et sa
tante semble heureux et épanoui sylvie
réalise alors que felipe a grandi sans
aide et que sa vie est désormais
ailleurs sur le schéma n'a fait divers à
forte tendance mélodramatique ce film
inspiré d'une histoire vraie sonne juste
à l'image de son interprétation il
emporte le spectateur à travers un
voyage existentiel où une mer se remet
en question fassent au bonheur ce que
son enfant a bâti sans elles et avec
d'autres le film pose des questions
essentielles sur la filiation et la
famille entre fragilité et impulsivité
isabelle carré joue le rôle d'une
magnifique mer en apprentissage quant à
ramzy bedia il s'en sort avec les
honneurs dans ce rôle inhabituel
son interprétation est à la fois
sensible et subtile avec douceur et
pudeur la mise en scène s'attache à
chaque détail du quotidien de ce petit
garçon
vous avez un petit garçon formidable
c'est pas possible un vaisseau lui faire
du mal
foutez moi
m
il ya pas de là
une vie ailleurs est à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret